لماذا فضح مرتضى منصور واقعه المخدرات في
الزمالك ازمه تنظيميه جديده في خليجي 25
بطلها ثنائي اسود الرافدين حرب بارده
تشتعل بين فكتوريا بيكرتها هذه الاخبار
وغيرها ننقلها لكم من العربيه رياضه
[موسيقى]
عامين من قبل الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
موضح
لن يظهر حتى تزول الماده الممنوعه من جسده
وانه قد طلب الرحيل
والى مدينه البصره العراقيه حيث ظهرت ازمه
تنظيميه جديده في بطوله خليجي خمسه
لاعبان سابقان لمنتخب اسود الرافدين حيث
انتشر مقطع فيديو يظهر فيه منع عماد محمد
وهوار ملا محمد اللاعبين السابقين لمنتخب
العراق من دخول ملعب جذع النخله من قبل
عناصر الامن بدريعه عدم امتلاكهما للتذاكر
مقطع الفيديو اثار السياقه عدد كبير من
مستخدم مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بسببي ما
تم وصفه بسوء تعامل العناصر المكلفه
بحمايه امن الملاعب مع النجم عراقيه
ننتقل الان للحديث عن الارجنتين الشعب
لخاندرو جار ناتشو الذي اشعل الاجواء داخل
صفوف قلعه اطرافورد مع كل الشياطين الحمر
والسبب لا يكمن حول مستواه الفني او
البدني في لقاء الفريق امام ايفرتون في
كاس الاتحاد الانجليزيه وانما بدايه
لسروال داخلي قصير يحمل العلامه التجاريه
للبرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو وهو امر اغضب
بعضا من مشجع مانشستر
الختام مع المغنيه ومصممه الازياء
العالميه فيكتوريا بيكام التي تعيش توترا
وحربا بارده بينها وبين زوجه ابنها ابنتها
نيكولا بيتلز بكم اعتقد الصحفيه تؤكد ان
فيكتوريا ونيكولا لا يتحدثان معا بسبب
توترات حدثت قبل واثناء فتره زفاف ابنها
وعلى ذمه المكتوب فان نيكولالا لم تعلق
باعجاب على اي من فساتين داري ازياء
حماتها على مدى شهرين قبل الزفاف وزاد
الامر سوءا باختيارها لفستان عرسها لمصمم
اخر منافس لفيكتوريا الامر لم يتوقف هنا
بل امتدا لمنافستي حماتها بظهور على غلاف
مجله مشهوره تحت عنوان عريض السيده بكم
الجديده انستغرام